i fasted during the month of ramadan and
alhamdulillah
after 30 days i've managed to do the
complete fast
and somewhere near the end of ramadan
that's when i had a dream i was
basically walking down a hallway to a
man sitting
at a couch and he was just smiling at me
so he has this really warm and friendly
presence
bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
and allah says that you know i've shown
you the signs in the horizons and all
around the world
and these two question that you know i
am your lord
i might not have witnessed enough for
you that this is the truth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
oh look at that stretch
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special guest salaam
alaikum how are you doing
so your muslim name is
and then your and i know your old name
was harold right
yes so what do you prefer we call you
what else that's great
is great i'm the last so a lot of our
viewers might be familiar with you that
saw your revered story but for those
that aren't tell us a little bit about
your story
cool uh how should i begin um okay maybe
i was born a catholic babe when i was
baptized when i was a baby
i went to church every sunday
i joined the band before i used to play
music
with the band
church goa most of the time
until about like 18 to 20 years old that
was when i started to serve the army in
singapore we have to it's a national
service all of us have to go to the army
um and then
i came back
and i needed to go travel overseas to
pursue my degree so when i went to
australia
and started to study about philosophy
and question a lot about the meaning of
life why we're here
um if
if reality is real or something like
that
so um and then i started to look deeper
into my past faith and discovered that
christianity wasn't something that
i really believe in because i started to
doubt the divinity of jesus
and
from then on i became more like an
atheist partying every day
i had this idea that if i'm happy i
could make everyone else around me happy
and that's perfect you can live a happy
life
and
so i started to live like a yolo kind of
life
a day at a time
look forward to the weekends kind of
thing
and
it was not until my parents gave me a
call and i was in school one day and
said that my grandma passed away and
that was when i thought
who is in control of death
because you know
as much as we want to be happy and to
make people around us happy
death is something that is
an unhappy event and you can't control
it
and that got me thinking that there has
to be a higher power out there someone
in control of death at least
so i started to ponder heart and thought
that there's probably a supreme being
in control of that aspect of life
and that was when i
i became agnostic
but i didn't want a religion to tell me
who god was because
i always had this idea that it was a
man-made thing
maybe because what studied in school you
know how they got us to understand that
you know all these are human constructs
we need something to believe in so that
we feel safe
but then again the idea of
you know know god is also
not logical because you know who can
control death
so i was agnostic but i didn't want a
religion
and then i came back to singapore that
was after i graduated from school
and when i came back i
started my job in the bank
and that's where i met a lady who is a
muslim
and she
we started to you know have a friendship
going on and feelings were starting to
develop
and i told upfront that you won't
you won't be together because you're a
muslim and i'm a yolo kind of person
so it's like two different visions in
life different aspects right so
how are we going to be together and she
said why don't you give islam a chance
go find out about it
and i said sure i mean i'm open-minded
enough to to give it a shot
but i'm going to ask the religious
teacher all my questions and if he can't
answer them
or if i find that it's not logical i'll
just you know back away i will not
believe in this religion and she said
fine go ahead ask all your questions so
she directed me to the convert center in
singapore
and that's when i went to the
introduction to islam course
it was very basic
like the belief of one god and who is
allah something like that
so i started writing writing down my
questions and i had three questions for
the teacher
and i asked him the first question was
why do you say there's only one god why
why is it like two or three or four
or why do you believe in just one god
and he said
well it's very very simple you know
he gave me this analogy that if there
was a god that made the human head and a
god made the human hands and a god had
made the human legs which god would say
that you know he is good enough to make
the human body complete and perfect
and the god that created the hate would
say i'm much better because i gave human
ideas and thoughts and intelligence
maybe the god of the hands would say i'm
better because i feed the man
or the god of the human legs to say i'm
better because you know i
take him to distant places
so there has to be a central point where
you know a god that's all-powerful
create decorated the human being in its
perfect form
and that made me think a lot but it
wasn't convincing enough so he went on
to say that what about
computers look at them you know you have
a monitor you have a mouse you have a
keyboard
but you still need a central power
source to to light it all up to start
the computer and that that gave me a
glimpse into the idea of tawheed the
belief in one god in islam and i thought
well that makes a lot of sense so
all the polytheistic religion suddenly
just didn't make any sense to me
if if they believe in like three or four
gods just wouldn't make any logical
sense so we came to a point of having
just three religions that believe in one
god which is
judaism christianity in islam
and so i asked him the next question
why didn't you say jesus is god or
buddha is god or anyone else is god why
do muslims call allah the god of all
and
he said
from a christian perspective if you
believe that jesus is god
the definition of divinity in dictionary
would mean that you know someone who
cannot die
and
if jesus was immortal
how is he
able to die die on a cross if for
christians you believe that he died on
the cross
and then i thought about he was third
day right and he said but you see
um then it would not be a complete
sacrifice because
um for
for sacrifice to be
accurate you know you will lose it
forever
and
then that would be uh proper sacrifice
and otherwise you know because
christians we you know as christians we
believe that
if
um for the sake of forgiving all our
sins
jesus died on the cross
and his blood kind of washes all of your
sins from the past and forgives you
and god forgives you through that act of
sacrifice so there's a need for a
sacrifice to happen otherwise
you know there's no forgiveness
and so
that that again brought in the next
question
he asked me would a god be more merciful
if he needs
you he needs to sacrifice an innocent
man
who is the son right in order to forgive
someone sin
or would you say a god is more merciful
if he just forgives you when you ask for
forgiveness
so that question alone
made so much sense like you know
you can just go up to your parents and
say you're sorry for something but why
can't god do the same like why can't you
just go up to god and say i'm sorry for
whatever i've done wrong
why do you need a sacrifice you know so
christianity was written off
from
from my my question and then buddhism so
i asked him about buddha
and he said buddhism is a way of life
but
the issue with buddhism is they do not
have a communication with god
they do not believe in a god and so a
follower of buddhism
knows how to lead a good life without a
guiding force without someone to connect
to
um a supreme being like god to to ask
you know for even your forgiveness to
ask for guidance you don't have someone
to communicate with
and that's what's lacking criticism so
that again made sense to me
so i asked so
why do muslims believe in so who who do
muslims believe and he said
allah we believe in
one true god the god the creator of all
things
he cannot be compared to anything and
basically he's not
give he's not born or he's not he
doesn't give birth to
so he he basically translated surah
aklas
um in english to me which is the
simplest way to explain
who god is to the muslims and that
sounded like something i have always
believed in like you always believe
there's a superpower supreme being out
there who created all things
and that made a lot of sense
and also because when i started
philosophy you know we had this
notion this this this course about
if people
could see god
how is it possible when we have five
limited senses for example you know your
eyes have
limited range you can see uh hearing as
well taste buds as well
so
with all that limitations
how we able to define what is real how
we able to define
uh divinity how do we find god with just
our limited senses the universe is
something that is so vast and big and
you can't use a ruler
to measure the universe but what we are
trying to do is measure the power of god
with our five senses
and that alone
kind of wake me up even more because i
thought like yeah that makes our sense
you know jesus couldn't be god because
he's he's a man right and you can see
everything about him
and god is way more powerful than that
he's the greater right so
um
so i i had uh started to believe in
islam but i didn't want to immediately
jump into the religion because i know
that there are a lot of you know things
that you have to do like fasting during
the month of ramadan
uh if possible you know perform your
heart and you have to eat a lot of food
and pray five times a day so those were
the conditions that you know islam has
set out to to guide people but at the
point of time i wasn't sure if i was
able to take all that so i tried one
step at a time like for example i would
stop eating pork and then stop
eating food that are not halal
and slowly slowly i you know even quit
drinking
and and then afterwards when just nice
you know ramadan came
and i said okay it's about time
it's about time i should give this a
shot because you know if i can fast for
the whole month of ramadan then i think
i can live a muslim life
and and you know it's about time also to
let my
girlfriend then know you know if this
religion is something i really want to
follow
and not waste the time
so
i i fasted during the month of ramadan
and alhamdulillah
after 30 days i've managed to do the
complete fast
and somewhere near the end of ramadan
that's when i had a dream
and i woke up one morning
and
before that the dream was i was
basically walking down a hallway to a
man sitting at a couch and he was just
smiling at me so he has this really warm
and friendly
presence towards him so i walked towards
him and he asked me a question he just
looked at me and smiled and said brother
when are you going to be part of the
family
and the moment i woke up
so i think i thought wow this is amazing
i mean probably i
have been
reading too much islam
maybe i started to dream islam
so um i didn't think much about it same
day my friend called me out
for for dinner
and
he's a muslim so he said hey his name is
ibrahim so it's it's quite amazing like
abraham ibrahim so he's like saying uh
hey brother so i saw you've been going
to the convert center are you thinking
of becoming a muslim i said well that's
a coincidence i just had a dream
just a few hours ago and this guy is
asking me the same question
so i thought okay maybe this is still a
coincidence
i went home that night and
so happened the dream
happened again and this time i woke up
it's a saturday morning i sat on my bed
um and then i i decided to say a short
prayer i said
dear god and i believe in you i believe
here they are powerful
um
i'm just a lost soul you know i'm
i need guidance right now and i seek
your help to to show me the way
and um i think
i'm tired of
you know this confusion please help me
um
i'm going to flip the bible in the quran
randomly three times
and whichever verse that my eyes set
upon i would just um
i would hope that is a clear message
from you saying that this is the truth
this is the way
and just follow me or something like
that
um and so i said okay i've studied the
bible since i was first a catholic i was
first baptized one so
i took the bible
and closed my eyes and i just friendly
opened a page and i was i can't remember
the verse on the page but
it wasn't clear the thing about the
bible is it's made of a lot of
testimonies and stories so
you know you can't just take a part and
just
kind of make sense out of it uh you can
have like 10 or 20 different
interpretations of the same verse
probably
and you can make it out to be whatever
you want sometimes so
i tried three times it wasn't very clear
it was like halfway through a story
you probably need to read the whole
story to understand that particular
verse that i read
so um like i said i can't remember which
verse so i can't quote it right now
so three three times i tried and it did
not sink into my heart so i just
i decided to
give the quran a shot the next one so
that's when i i said okay put the bible
down it's time for the quran
look out the quran is an english
translation of the quran
i closed my eyes and opened the first
thing i saw was in surah al hajj
there's a chapter of 22
verse 54
54
and it's it goes like uh do you want me
to to recite it oh yeah i'll go ahead go
for it
[Music]
bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
i mean i can't remember the english one
but i know in general what it means it
says that you know i've given knowledge
to those who who seek it and
isn't it obvious enough that this is the
truth for me a lot
and and for those who believe in their
hearts humbly submit to it something
like that
so um
i i thought okay maybe this is
a coincidence i was still in denial you
know
and i closed the book again and said
okay this is the second try
and close my eyes and again i flipped
open a new page and i was brought to
surah fusilla chapter 41 53
and it goes
bismillah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and allah says that you know i've
shown you the signs in the horizons and
all around the world
and these two questions that you know i
am your lord
am i not a witness enough for you that
this is the truth so
it's like
he was even answering he was continuing
the question of you know does he exist
in the next verse although it's from a
different part of the quran
and immediately my heart was like
trembling in all you know that
like as if i was really having
conversation with god at this point of
time
i i humbled myself i i kind of like have
tears in my eyes and i said thank you
for answering my prayers and
you know i'm sorry for opening you to
the test
i i've now that i've declared to you
that i've followed
you know we follow you
based on this test right
um there's nothing that's going to pull
me back and from that day or forward i
said i submit to you from my heart and
i believe in islam
so i i gave the convert center a call i
said
uh how do i become muslim and and then
they they brought me into to take my
shahadah so
that's that's the reverse story and of
course i told my
my girlfriend then i said um
i got something good to tell you
that i've decided to be a muslim and
she she was so happy and she said you
know how many nights of tahajuds i did
just to ask allah
to guide you to to the path
and um i mean she's such an angel that
you know we we got married and so that's
how we have our now we have our child
the son
and that's that's
the love ending i'll say the love story
of it
yeah
thank you so that's the story yeah
and that was beautiful the recitations
by the way yeah
yeah
bro i wanted to say something
real quick that
maybe like i could relate to you on a
personal level on this and a lot of our
viewers might as well that when you talk
about how at the end allah gave you that
perfect you know that
you know when you watch movies and you
know they talk about this beautiful
ending to the story right
that subhanallah allah granted us like
the perfect ending that it could have
been you know what i mean like allah
could have taken one thing away from us
i've been like you know what you were
doing this or you were doing that or you
know i'll take this away from you and
humble you
but allah really could have done that
but chose to give us that perfect
forever after type ending you know so
i'm eternally grateful for that and i
know you are too
yes thank you brother
yeah
i can relate to the uh the part where
you read the quran you felt like allah
is talking to you you're discussing with
allah i feel like that
that feeling you get like the shivers
down your spine you feel that that void
that was in your heart is now filled and
you're like the one who made me the one
who created me the one who owns
everything the one who if i just say you
know
upon him i i rely on if i just say that
and he'll take care of everything this
is the person or not the person but this
is the you know the existence this is
allah well i'm now speaking to
subhanallah it's such a beautiful
feeling
that that arises in the heart and i i
felt that again when you were telling
your story because i'm just like allah
like that is guidance
upon a person asking for guidance would
never misguide them never leave them
astray
and allah may allah bless you bro
because that story was
like my my tears aren't crying my my
eyes aren't crying like unhealed but my
heart is
100.
[Music]
like i i literally started feeling like
tuna i was like no no but you you
so my next question to you is do you
know how a lot of people say that uh if
you sincerely cry out to allah to guide
me
allah will guide you know how everyone
says that's true
now there's a lot of atheists that are
saying or they they claim to say that i
do cry out to god i do try to reach out
to god and i don't get anything i don't
get guidance
so god doesn't exist does he hate me
does he not like me does he not want to
guide me so do you think the issue with
them
is that they really haven't fully cried
out
i think there's a couple of issues there
uh one
yeah i believe in
sincere and humble submission like you
need to really
want the truth
so badly
that you give up everything for it kind
of thing
um secondly you need to ask with an
earnest heart
um and pray in in sense like it's your
last day
and you really want him to show you
because you know he doesn't need to show
you because he can say look around you
and that is
my creations and you will know who i am
right but you are forcing him sort of
like you're putting him in a spot
to show you something that's that's the
other thing
um
thirdly i think because i went through
fasting
kind of like i think physically i've
prepared
to let anything happen
sort of so i think maybe that kind of
prepared me for this
um and so that's that's the three things
uh next is i think the the perspective
of how we want something to happen you
know in in in human terms we we need
you know maybe a a volcano t rock then
you say oh there's a god or something or
thunder and lightning right
um
but you see we are again relying so
heavily on our five senses and yet they
have we have people that can't see in
their whole life and believe in god or
who can cannot hear anything who are
like lacking one of these five senses
and they believe in god um so they have
no one to influence them who god is
like for example you have a deaf person
who has never heard an imam talk to him
or her about god but they believe in god
so
that that alone shows you a lot about
you know
how narrow-minded a person is not open
enough to accept that
there is a creator of all things and you
know you can't argue with
um
how can the universe come about if it
starts from zero right
zero can't create one
yeah so that alone has logic logical
flaws if you believe that things can
just happen without god yeah
but it reminds me of uh
it didn't it made sense it made perfect
sense
it reminded me of uh the conversation i
was having with my grandpa yesterday
and um
you know we were actually debating about
because he he's he's proper christian
and he was asking me
like why am i muslim like why do i read
the quran but um
aside from that once we found common
grounds
he was saying that uh people
don't really
experience god or they don't
they don't experience that guidance
until all they have is nothing but god
whereas like everything is stripped away
and it's like once you give up
everything that's when
god like truly guides you because that's
when you are truly sincere when you have
nothing left and it's like a lot of
people might misinterpret that and say
like oh do i have to give up my house
do i have to give up my relationships do
i have to give up my job
it's like no
but for that time being you have to
fully submit and like give up everything
in your mind stop being so damn attached
to things to be able to sincerely
come to the creator for that guidance so
i'm the good job bro marshall
well said yeah that's exactly what i
mean yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so how old are you again
uh 34
34 yeah okay see i was thinking you were
like
in your 20s right oh you look good for
34 marshall
yeah so so a lot of people are watching
and they don't know that you know you're
married you have a kid too so uh tell me
some lessons that you've learned as a
father now um from before when you
didn't have any kids
so
um even after reversion allah still puts
us to the test
and as a father i know there are certain
things that i recognize as a test from
god for example um
you know when you spend more time with
your work instead of spending more time
with family
sometimes you see in your eyes the the
the child's eyes you know when they look
at you and say you know as though he's
saying you're not home you haven't seen
for some time
and could you be here more with me so he
started to cry
so so when babies cry sometimes you
think you know they're being
misbehaving some of us might think that
way but actually it's indication to you
as a parent that you've been missing out
in the person's life
and and i think um
i take a lesson from that like i should
spend more time with my children
my child and
to really know how to balance between
what's in the dunya what's in the hera
and what have you know allah has blessed
you with
you should not take them for granted so
you know
sometimes my wife would tell me you
should remember this and this
this kind of wakes me up again so even
as a revert we are always
you know put ourselves in a position to
be reawaken over and over again because
when you're real awake and you know that
allah is
it loves you right he puts you to the
test that's like that's why he he puts
you to test yeah
so
how has it been like now that
you have a kid like because
is it what you expected
oh is it something completely different
i always go with the flow
yeah it was like um okay i we we were
prepared to have kids it wasn't
something like we we
we it was an accident something like
that we really wanted to have a kid
um
we
we prayed and asked for blessings from
allah
i would say that
now when i look at my kid's eye and i
look at the situation of our current you
know world
and that what scares me is his future of
course
and
i mean i was a rebellious child when i
was young
i could have just listened to my parents
and you know stay a christian
or or you know just tell the girl that
or just you know tell myself i can meet
another girl why would i need to go
through the whole process of finding
islam
and all that
i guess somehow a part of me really
wanted to know the meaning of life and
and truth and all that
so when i see my my my child in the
future i'm worried about you know
whether he get influenced by friends or
something or
or music or something that you know
takes him far away from islam
so i do whatever i can to
to
to
you know
build bridges for him to god
what i mean is you know a wise man once
told me that you know the role of a
father is not so much as
um someone who
just educates or
or just called your son if he's not he's
misbehaving or something but the role of
a father is more
like a person who you know
builds a lot of bridges or
lays the ropes
that brings the person back home to
allah
um so in the event of your death or in
the event you know
um
you she gets lost
at least your child can remember these
ropes that you lay for him and and
return home
and
because he can't control his destiny
when he reaches
puberty or you know 18 or 20 years old
he will have his own mind he will have
his own friends
and he'll go through a whole
a whole face of his own
so all you can do is now establish the
ropes
as much as you can guide him as much as
you can
and uh inshallah he will still be
guided even the hero to the hereafter
yeah so what i do is i do videos there's
the whole reason why i started my own
youtube channel was
mainly to
you know put this information out there
this knowledge i gathered over the years
online so it's like a digital library of
information
and if if one day should i you know
untimely death or anything
he still have these places to go to to
find information so that's what i do
and that's what i take from being a dad
to think of the future for my children
so i saw one video saying catholic dad
reacts to my reversion from you i didn't
watch it though because i i think i was
so excited with your reverb video that i
was just sending it to people uh but for
me and a lot of people that haven't seen
that video tell me how your parents
reacted
okay
and and before that you i don't think
you you told us if you did i probably
forgot when did you revert
oh 2014 and november 2nd so that's about
seven over years ago yeah
um my dad
he's a very strong uh
believer and
catholicism yeah catholic believer
um
i know in his heart he really wants me
to come back to being to be a christian
um but i
i know where i i want what i want
um but i love him dearly and my mom
daily so
when i do the video i of course i told
them you know the purpose of the video
is
to be candid to be free to be you know
share your ideas and thoughts and be
comfortable with it
um and
most importantly know that i love you as
a son and
i would like to know hear what you have
your thoughts about me being a muslim so
that's how i started making the video
um and my dad was sharing his thoughts
about it and i use it as a way to also
you know get him to understand more
about islam
and
in the video
uh i just been asking some basic
questions like you know don't you know
that
we are from the abrahamic faith we are
all
children of abraham ibrahim
um and
do you know that even if you don't know
this like christianity is actually a
middle eastern religion because
it started in the middle east right
but everyone has this idea that it looks
like an european thing
and and that itself kind of blocks you
from
you know looking at it from a holistic
way
uh and it's not just separate arabs as
you know they're just all muslims right
and jews are jews right and christians
are europeans but not true because jesus
is a palestinian right
so now you start to see it in that way
you start to see that actually we all
are middle east we all believe in the
middle eastern religion right it came
from the middle east
and um and that i hope can break some
barriers to see that we are still united
in in faith in the sense that we believe
in one god in his perspective he thinks
you know the trinity is one god
um
but of course i try to make sense out of
that
and never try to be disrespectful in any
way so the video just covers those areas
of his thoughts
and what about your mother
my mom
my mom is more um
because she's she's not
a christian or anything she's she's been
a free thinker for the longest time
but
she just followed customs and traditions
which
her parents taught her when she was
young
so
she always thought that it was the
guiding light because
you're following your parents for many
years and suddenly someone's telling you
that you know what your parents are
doing it's not right it's you know an ss
this is not necessary and stuff so she
she also couldn't um
she couldn't see why islam is the way
but
she does it what she doesn't know is
what she already believe in is very
islamic like
she believes in in the existence of a
god a creator a one god
he believes that you know when we pray
we are communicating with god and that's
why it's necessary to pray as often as
we can that you should pray
during the day
before you go to work to thank god you
know and to ask for protection
and then you should also pray at least
before you sleep because that's when you
thank god for all the things he blessed
you so
even for five daily prayers you agree
two out of five release of the prayer
you need to do
and um she understands why it's
important
to eat halal food because harald food is
cleaner and stuff so she has this
understanding and concept but what she
hasn't
given is her whole heart into islam
maybe because she thinks she still has
this lens over her thinking that
you know it's it's a middle eastern
religion and it's not the same culture
as us how can we
embrace a religion that is so different
from us you know that kind of thinking
so
um and you see on tv right people with
beards means they are muslim or
something or people
people who look arab or they're all
muslims right but if you start people
like that when they start seeing their
own race or their own country or people
doing the same thing then they start to
think yeah maybe it's true you know
so i think the media plays a very
important part in
showing a more balanced view
um instead of something that's
polarizing
yeah but i can only pray to allah and
ask for he he died to be given to her
yeah
i mean
inshallah i don't want to steal all the
questions because i know that the other
two might have some questions so do you
guys have anything to say or
should i go on
romney's been a little quiet yeah
honestly i've just been this is it's
usually when we have a really great
guest on the show allah i just sit and i
reflect and i think about you know what
they're saying
um and uh when i get in that moment i
get really quiet but allah like the
story really strikes me especially when
it comes to your parents and what you
just spoke about subhanallah uh
one thing one piece of advice at least
one reminder i want to give is is it's
really important to
one
look at them as sometimes the sources
said when he came on look at them was
like a blank canvas right even if they
have to stop seeing them as mom and dad
for a second just look at you know who
they are what they stand for what they
believe their personality just look at
them as a blank canvas and kind of build
off of that and also come to to common
terms with what you can so for example
if your mom doesn't want to give up
culture then tell her she doesn't
necessarily have to give up culture
right she still has her culture her
background her upbringing it's just
taking the true pure belief
and and applying it to where it's to be
applied like for example if if she
believed in some scientific theories is
that gonna come and ruin her culture no
not necessarily so if you believe in one
god and this religion there may be some
things where it's like okay this is not
allowed
and you remove that from the culture but
all together
if you look at the holistic picture you
don't really have to give up you know
who you are it's not like you're gonna
be an auto like trans trans uh ethnic
autumn or something all of a sudden
so uh
but yeah in regards to everything else
bro allah the story is
so touching
may allah bless you for sharing it with
us and then for your youtube and bless
you and your family but what you said
about having a you know a son and being
a father i'm not a father yet man but i
thought about it a lot and i just
brought like a whole new perspective
subhanallah which is probably why i'm so
deep in thought but
about laying the ropes
yeah and that's why they said you know
about being an imam in the family yeah
something like like you're the the guy
who lays the ropes even for your wife to
join you in jannah so that's one of the
the thing that the guy told me is that
wow that's the role of the father so
that's why allah puts you up in a
different kind of like a father status
right
um so it's always good for a muslim to
get married to be a father and to
to play that role
it gives you a greater insight into you
know the mercy of allah
yeah because when the father prays our
mother prays you know allah listens to
to what he please to allah he asks for
help and stuff right
um and you're right brother you
mentioned because i'm sorry i was just
responding to that um
you're right to say that
um
you can still do the culture and stuff
but the only issue is because
what you see around you like your
friends right
this is maybe might might sound like a
bit weird because in in in in in
singapore at least right when we see
somebody with a hijab on
they start to recognize it as a
particular race of people wearing the
hijab you know so they think it's all
malays that were in the hijab
and actually you have chinese also in
hijab so they couldn't see past that and
then think that it's a malay religion
so so what happened is it's also
reinforced by by the media or even from
religious bodies themselves that say
malay muslim they like to add the
ethnicity
with the the religion and and that
creates an image in a person's mind
thinking that
you know you must be a malay and you can
be a muslim
something like that you know
so so so that the challenge is for us
doing darwin is to to break that
um the perception to see that it's
universal religion and to also see that
it's possible to still keep certain
parts of the cultures now it doesn't go
against the religion
you can do that and sometimes people
don't listen to logic i realize
and so when you recite al-fatiha or you
recite some parts of the quran and you
explain those verses to them in their
language
they are more likely to you know submit
like my mom she started crying after i
recited fatiha you should watch that
video yeah she's i mean like she had a
bit of tears and said i've never heard
you pray to me before
i said well nobody prays in front of you
mom
you know
you'll pray in secret people don't
really you know come up to you mom i'm
going to pray to you now
but
i mean maybe in church last time i don't
know but um
it's the most it's sweeter to do in
secret right so but i told her that
because there's healing qualities in the
prayer when you listen to this you feel
like as if just close your eyes and just
immerse yourself in the experience of
listening to the arabic words that are
recited so when i did the fatiha for her
it was an experience more than than
telling what is right or wrong and that
experience was what gave her you know
uh tears in her eyes or you know a
humble heart after that so she was more
calm after you decide something
something to take home with you i think
man that's something i learned in my
adult life at least that you know you
don't always need that perfect
philosophical argument
or religious argument to uh put someone
in their place or challenge them or
debate them you know where everyone is
just someone walking around that needs
to be refuted
right it's almost like leading by
example first
and also then following up with just
guiding them and showing them the beauty
of islam and oftentimes it's it's better
to say little and mean more than to say
too much
so my next question would be being a
muslim for the last seven ish years for
you
seven eight years
what advice would you have because as as
we try to be good men
in and lead people by example we realize
that it's better that we can guide
people to not make the mistakes that we
have right just because you know it's
kind of like what you would do for your
son you wouldn't want him going through
the same mistakes that you had to go
through through trial and error so
if you had someone that's a new revert
and they just became most important they
just embraced islam today they're
probably like there's a lot of
information there's a lot of life
changes we have to do
what plan would you give them you know
i think that's a great question in fact
i think um what i do is
okay this is what it one of the things
that it taught us in the army is to be a
thinking soldier
so we always ask questions but i think
they regretted that because now i ask a
lot of questions
so what i'm saying is okay
um always have a reason or like an
understanding to back up what you say
that is going to help your child to grow
spiritually or intellectually as well
um that's why it's so important for us
to seek knowledge so as muslims seek the
right knowledge as well
seek the right knowledge and to increase
yourself in knowledge so that
when your your children ask you a
question you have many ways of answering
them
um in the way that they would listen um
so
for me i was inquisitive i needed a lot
of answers
and a part of me also needed action so i
need to see person to a person
performing the example for me
um so
so you have to live by the quran right
that's why the quran has the hadith and
all that you need to follow it closely
so our children when they observe
children observe
most of the time and they copy and they
follow they mimic that's their way of
showing love right
so that's why the first thing you teach
your child is when you you pray you just
ask him to sit beside you and just watch
you first
and then eventually they learn to pray
um also you know get your family
together to pray
because it will help you to build a
stronger bond with your wife and
children and
you know it's really hard to get angry
with someone after you pray
right or even before you pray after you
take a wudu
uh it's so hard to feel angry after that
because it's supposed to feel calm don't
take it like a process
don't take it like a motion that you
just have to do but always have this
inner
side of you know thinking you know why
am i doing this and
the purpose of doing this is to get
closer to allah to purify my thoughts
you know something like that instead of
oh i need to take it this way
sometimes as muslims i think what i
found out is we focus so much on the
technicalities the the little details
what's halal and what's haram and
all those little things that we forgot
the big picture we've become so
microscopic that we don't see the big
picture and when we lose the big picture
that's the problem because we can't
guide people
if we lose the big picture people see
the big picture as a vision
to towards islam
and when we start to focus on little
things
we can't you know impart that knowledge
across
so what i would say is always have both
view the microscopic one is to guide the
little things but the biggest view like
the open view you should have also as a
muslim and the only way to have that is
to increase your knowledge and to look
for different teachers also you know not
just one teacher to guide you in fact
yeah most importantly the guiding star
should be the quran
and the hadees and of course
your teachers that you look for yeah
that's all i can say
and have you undergone any type of like
education after that like when you
recited those uh those uh ayat your uh
tajweed was very good mashallah so do
you have any uh education that you went
through or was it mainly like kind of
self-taught
uh yeah so
for the ogama part of gaining knowledge
i i had a teacher that you know the guy
who
who helped me with shahadah he also have
classes so i started to go for his
classes because i wanted to learn more
about islam so he shared about the
stories of the prophets and the four
khalifs and so and so forth so that's
where i got basic knowledge on islam
regarding tajweed
my my family in my in-laws they have an
indonesian gustazer who actually guides
the family in you know reciting the
quran
so
i tag along and join them during the
classes
um strange thinking this is a this is a
miracle because
she only speaks bahasa indonesian
and a bit of english and you know i'm
chinese right in ethnicity not from
china singapore so some people get
confused
the ethnicity is chinese
and
i speak english
and very little malay which is the the
native language of my wife
so
so technically
we can't really communicate me and this
doesn't
she she just keep repeating the
the quran in arabic and bahasa indo
and after a while
i picked it up it's strange
that i could pick up two language at the
same time i was picking up a bit of
indonesian and
and
arabic
yeah but i guess of course i was really
interested to really learn the quran i
i have this goal in life to
hopefully memorize the whole quran
on to recite it over and over again
because it's just
so healing to the heart right
so so it was it was also that you know
initial fire in me that wanted to do
that that i was pursuing it so much i
would download muslim pro i would you
know
get the books and stuff
so i guess that's how i progressed in in
reciting the quran
and yeah
how many ies do you know
i guess
um
i mean
about
12 maybe 13
was surah al-murk
and
after i memorized muluk i was like every
night now it's my my child's lullaby i
try to to recite that to for him to
sleep
and it works man works it works and you
should
and i'm pretty sure we're supposed to
recite sort of before you fall asleep
like there's a process and i'm
specifying that as well
yeah i believe it was sort of sort of
not what i felt like and so that class
right
yes
all right any uh any questions for you
for us you know let us know
um
i don't i i'm very happy that you know
you have this podcast going and you have
a band of brothers here
you know trying to share islam with the
world i hope there are many of such
people out there as well doing it
um we live in a time where you know
digital is at our
age right we have we have this digital
landscape platform ready for us to share
things
and
what better way to to spread you know
the the beauty of islam
now that it's easily available to
everyone and i think we should not miss
this opportunity
um given you know the digital landscape
having said that of course not to forget
also the old ways of learning even
though we have a digital landscape
sometimes the old things do work better
yeah that's true
yeah i'm i'm a big fan of you know old
stuff too um
and um
i really hope inshallah to meet all of
you even
in person and this whole pandemic is
over i can
we can meet somewhere centralized or
something easy
most importantly to meet all of you so
in general for adults right that's our
main goal
yeah
masha'allah very touching episode very
touching episode you really packed my
shot allah
i have thank you guys more questions
just ask
i'm okay yeah yeah yeah
no worries guys if you made it this far
comment down below hashtag bring those
back
and insha allah you will see him in the
future with that being said also check
the link in the description box for his
channel go over and subscribe to his
channel watch his videos he posts
content regularly and inshallah we will
see him again
five with that being said
for an amazing episode and an amazing
story may allah bless you immensely and
we look to we hope to have you back
insha'allah soon
with that being said
head man
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i'm
going to agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zordsis we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm